[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal
préparé par la rédaction de tv 78 nous
sommes le mercredi 24 juin voici les
titres de cette édition
en ces jours de chaleur elles sont les
bienvenues les piscines ont été
autorisés à rouvrir avec la nouvelle
phase de déconfinement à montigny le
bretonneux on se prépare pour accueillir
à nouveau le public à partir de demain
reportages et garder son logement au
frais pendant l'été faire des travaux de
rénovation énergétique quelques-uns des
sujets des webinaires organisé par là
l'ex kayes à l' agence locale de
l'énergie et du climat a repris ses
activités
à la crise sanitaire at elle fait
prendre conscience aux saint quentinois
de l'urgence climatique
éléments de réponse et puis ils sont de
retour chez eux les pistards de l'équipe
de france ont retrouvé le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la semaine
dernière pour reprendre l'entraînement
un protocole strict a été mise en place
alors que les températures atteignent
des sommets en termes de chaleur leur
réouverture vont apporter un vent de
fraîcheur depuis le 15 juin les piscines
ont la possibilité de rouvrir moyennant
des mesures sanitaires pour accéder au
bassin au centre aquatique du lac de
montigny le bretonneux tout a été
préparé pour accueillir les nageurs
le reportage de mathilde et demi il n'y
aura que 100 places disponibles dans les
bassins pour des créneaux de deux heures
le centre aquatique du lac a revu toute
son organisation et à installer un
protocole strict pour l'entrée nous
mettons à disposition cette zone là de
cabine
on voit au sol le marquage pour
respecter la distance le cabinet après
avoir désinfecté la cabine qui viendra
d'être utilisés permettra au nouvel
usager d'y accéder la personne se change
on la retrouve de l'autre côté pour
accueillir les nageurs des cabinets ont
été mis à disposition pour les guider
jusqu'au vestiaire
une fois changé ils sont ensuite emmenés
jusqu'aux douche et au bassin les gens
qui pourront venir devront au préalable
s'inscrire donc nous avons dû aussi
mettre en place sur le site internet
le gris d'inscription qui leur permet de
venir et puis nous avons privilégié
évidemment le
le passage des personnes de montigny et
de voisins qui sont les deux co
propriétaire de l'établissement pour une
ligne d'eau il faudra compter sillage
heures maximum le bonnet de bain qui est
obligatoire doit être systématiquement
plonger dans du désinfectant avant
d'être utilisées et les serviettes
doivent être placés dans les gradins à
des endroits précis de tout temps même
en dehors de l'aco vide
l'eau est désinfecté désinfectantes nous
avons fait le choix de que ce soit par
le chlore est donc en l'occurrence à
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune étude qui
pourrait démontrer qu'il y aurait des
risques potentiels à pratiquer la
natation dans un espace aquatique et
ludique comme celui ci la piscine
accueillera donc jeudi 25 juin les
nageurs
quant aux salles de fitness et de
musculation de l'espace forme du centre
elles rouvriront à partir du lundi 29
jan et alors que les déplacements ont
repris un rythme quasi normal et que la
température devrait attendre 35 degrés
demain en ile-de-france un pic de
pollution est prévu dans la région pour
la journée de jeudi air parif
l'organisme chargé de surveiller la
qualité de l'air sur le territoire
annonce un épisode de pollution à
l'ozone avec un dépassement du seuil
d'information
l'agencé régionale de santé préconise de
limiter les sorties et sport intense en
plein air pour la journée de demain
jeudi
une question alors que la pollution fait
son retour le confinement et la crise
sanitaire ont-ils fait prendre
conscience de l'urgence climatique
elle nous avons posé la question à l'
agence locale de l'énergie et du climat
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'alec sky
a repris ses activités
l entretien est menée par nicolas landry
avec nous sébastien mêlée directeur de
l'agencé locale de l'énergie et du
climat de saint-quentin-en-yvelines plus
connu sous le nom de la l'ex caille
bonjour bonjour alors là l'express est
une association créée en 2001 par la
communauté d'agglomération
leur mission c'est informer sensibiliser
et accompagner les habitants les
entreprises et les collectivités sur les
questions de transition environnementale
alors comment s'est passé le
déconfinement qu avec vous et comment
vous avez vous repris votre activité
alors très progressivement évidemment
mais on a la chance agences de pas avoir
vraiment stopper l'activité
c'est à dire que l'été c'est une période
propice aux dons
on est plutôt nous en grosse activité
sur la période hivernale période de
chauffe c'est là on est en visite où on
est le plus sollicité par les
particuliers donc on a on a pu tous tes
ruse âge du télétravail et notamment
maintenir un certain niveau de
permanence donc l'alternance physique
rendez vous ont bien évidemment été
stoppée néanmoins on a conservé on a
innové aussi on a on a découvert des
permanences en visioconférence et on a
continué sur le service au moins
téléphonique vous avez organisé
différents webinaire notamment à tout à
fait ne pouvant pas touché ou informés
via nos ateliers habituels les
particuliers les usagers du territoire
on a trouvé une solution qui est pas
très original pour cette période l'homme
etc et le webinaire qui ont assez bien
marché on a eu on a fait le plein à
chaque fois de d'inscrits par rapport à
on va dire des bonnes capacités pour
pouvoir échanger puis sont visionnables
sur le compte youtube de la de l'alec
donc n'hésitez pas aussi s'il n'y avait
pas assisté à aller visionner ses dévots
binaire d'informations sûres sur des
grandes caractéristiques de même édition
que ce soit sur la rénovation ou sur des
écogestes on peut appliquer tous les
jours alors l'une des thématiques
justement abordé lors de ces webinaire
c'est les astuces pour conserver son
logement au frais et ça tombe bien parce
que cette semaine le thermomètre dépasse
les 30 degrés est ce que vous pouvez
nous donner quelques astuces et donner
quelques astuces aux téléspectateurs
pour conserver leur logement au frais
face à ces hautes températures
puis tout à fait on a même eu
désinformation pas très bonne sur
l'arctique où on est à on a atteint des
records à 37 38 degrés ces derniers
jours malheureusement ça fait que
confirmer les scénarios du giec même
peut-être les plus optimistes les
astuces pour le logement pour rester au
frais je dirais que la première c'est
d'avoir déjà un logement bien qu'ils
aient un logement bien isolé c'est la
garantie de conserver un certain niveau
de fraîcheur de nos logements sans
engager de travaux ou en attendant il ya
quand même des astuces c'est déjà se
protéger enfin ventiler et aérer fr
une circulation d'air et puis se
protéger en fête du soleil c'est les
rayons du soleil qui apporte aussi la
chaleur donc fermer les rideaux des
choses comme ça bien s'hydrater ça
permet aussi tout simplement de ne tenir
la chaleur il ya des paramètres de santé
qui sont très fortement lié à ces
paramètres caniculaire de confort on l'a
vu un cette pandémie a entraîné un choc
économique la priorité des gouvernements
dans le monde entier aujourd'hui c'est
la relance économique
une relance qui se veut parfois verte
pour assurer aussi une transition
environnementale comment vous au
quotidien vous agissez auprès des
entreprises pour justement les
accompagner dans cette transition
environnementale
alors c'est une de nos missions
effectivement c'est déjà travaillé sur
la maîtriser l'énergie
on suit à la lettre qu'on appelle la
démarche négawatt qui était une démarche
simplement de bon sens un qui a été
conçu par un panel de scientifiques de
l'association négawatt qui se décline en
trois volets sobriété efficacité
renouvelables le premier poste d'abord
la sobriété supprimer les gaspillages
on sait sur ce poste là qu'on va
travailler en priorité ça passe par la
maîtrise de l'énergie et le suivi des la
maîtrise de ses consommations d'énergie
aussi donc le premier accompagnement
qu'on peut proposer aux notamment
petites entreprises c'est travailler sur
ces postes de maîtrise des consommations
énergétiques ça fait diminuer les
charges
ça va être sur les factures
d'électricité ça peut être l'éclairage
dans une boutique donc là on a un
certain nombre d'actions qu'on peut
proposer aux loups tpe sur une partie du
territoire pouvoir que la reprise si
elle peut se faire dans une dune manière
un peu plus verte comme vous dites plus
en adéquation avec la transition
énergétique c'est surtout une
opportunité au niveau de l'emploi il ya
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'emplois qui reste
à créer et beaucoup d'opportunités
économiques
donc c'est un vrai levier de relance à
cette transition énergétique
pour conclure peut-être qu'on ne le voit
pas encore mais croyez vous que cette
urgence sanitaire qu'on a connus ces
derniers mois va permettre de prendre
conscience ou en tout cas de renforcer
la prise de conscience autour de
l'urgence climatique
d'une certaine manière oui alors sur
luge en ski
matic peut-être pas directement pour les
moins convaincus mais en tout cas elle a
fait la mis en avant cette période
combien de passes et l'a mis en avant
des des nouvelles possibilités soit en
termes de consommation en termes de vie
ensemble au niveau de la santé aussi des
nouvelles préoccupations qui vont
rejoindre de toute façon les thématiques
climatiques qui sont très transversal et
très globale quand on parle de
changement climatique ou transition
écologique énergétique
on touche en fait à tous les domaines
soit le bâtiment la rénovation avec les
les entreprises c'est un nouveau gros
sujets aussi notamment via la plateforme
repères habitat et puis l'émission
conseil mais ça passe aussi par des
questions de santé de mobilité on a vu
on a pu mesurer concrètement l'impact
d'un changement assez radical de
mobilité aujourd'hui sur nos territoires
c'est vraiment très transversal ça
touche tout donc je pense que chacun en
fonction des thématiques qui lui sont
peut-être les plus chères auquel il sera
le plus sensible va trouver matière à
procès dans la transition énergétique
merci sébastien mêlée merci à vous
directeur de l'agencé locale de
l'énergie et du climat de saint quentin
en yvelines
[Musique]
l'actualité c'est aussi le scrutin des
municipales j - 4 avant le second tour
ce dimanche d'ici la présentation des
candidats s'engagent et attrapes ils
sont 3 avec notamment othman nassr ou
tête de liste d'engagements trappe
citoyens deuxième après le premier tour
nous lui avons donné deux minutes pour
vous convaincre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la liste d'union locale que je porte
avec mustapha larfaoui c'est une vraie
liste de rassemblement
je sais que certains veulent faire de
cette élection un débat uniquement entre
à droite et la gauche sauf que nous on a
construit quelque chose qui dépasse très
largement les clivages droite gauche des
gens de toutes sensibilités
mustapha larbaoui et d'une sensibilité
politique qui n'est pas la mienne et
pourtant nous sommes réunis avec un vrai
projet sur les dossiers parce qu'en
réalité on a face à nous deux candidats
issus de la majorité sortante d'une
majorité qui se déchire et ont tous les
deux été aux responsabilités et qu'ils
ont tous les deux ans les chèques par un
certain nombre de sujets par exemple à
l'arrêt de la bétonisation de trappes
qui s'est énormément densifie ces
dernières années je suis le seul
candidat à avoir voté contre les
opérations de promotion immobilière jeux
partout dans la ville selon sans que
l'on n'ait plus aucun espace vert aucun
espace de stationnement et il est
aujourd'hui un quotidien de plus en plus
difficile je pense aux services de
proximité le tout n'est pas uniquement
d'avoir des beaux slogans la bouche mais
en matière de santé il a fallu que ce
soit la région
à ma demande qui viennent financer le
cabinet médical qui a ouvert en merisier
et nous aurons demain cabinet médical
une maison de santé pluridisciplinaire
du même type au quartier j'aurais
souvenirs qu'aujourd'hui aucun médecin
généraliste
je pense à la fiscalité là aussi manière
très concrète pendant la deuxième taxe
foncière la plus élevée des yvelines
nous laver ce qu elle a augmenté de 10%
la trappe en 2015 mes deux adversaires
en beauté main dans la main cette
augmentation
naturellement nous reviendrons à un
niveau beaucoup plus convenable vous le
voyez à chaque fois sur deux sujets très
très concret très pratique nous avons un
projet cohérent constant dans le temps
et la capacité de mettre en oeuvre et de
finance
[Applaudissements]
c'est quelque chose que vous ferons
ensemble je crois c'est relancer la
concertation avec les craintes la
concertation d'abord sur les codes que
venait nous reviendrons à la semaine de
quatre jours mais tout cela s'organise
et nous voulons le faire dans le
dialogue avec la communauté éducative
les parents d'élèves et les enseignants
c'est un dialogue qui a beaucoup manqué
à trappes ces dernières années il ya
bien sûr la concertation c'est tout
c'est que le comité de quartier ces
derniers grands projets de rénovation
qui reste je pense à camille je prends
ça c'est une nouvelle à barbusse je
pense à malines 10 pour laquelle il n'y
a encore beaucoup d'aménagements à faire
pour améliorer réellement la calcule
reprendre le dialogue avec des
trappistes dans l'apaisement dans la
sérénité et aussi surtout dans le
rassemblement
aujourd'hui on a besoin de tout le monde
pour faire réviser à wimereux trois
candidats également en vue de ce second
tour notamment jean baptiste à monique
arrivé en tête le 15 mars dernier
il mène la liste villepreux
naturellement deux minutes également
pour lui afin de vous convaincre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une liste qui s'est constitué en
septembre dernier qui est resté uni et
solide pendant tout le temps de la
campagne et du confinement une liste
plurielle
une liste qui rassemble à la fois des
anciens élus et des villes prose ya
engagé dans le monde associatif ou tout
simplement engagée sur la ville dans
diverses activités qu'il y avait l'envié
de se retrouver et de partager un projet
commun pour la ville donc une liste
plurielle je me disais expérimentés et
plein de compétences et à l'image
surtout représentative de l'ensemble des
bides provient et des habitants de la
commune notre programme on l'entend
aujourd'hui en sortie de crise par l'est
de la ville de demain et des différentes
transitions qu'il faudrait engager
transition écologique sociale solidaire
économique notamment tout ce toutes ces
transitions là nous les avions déjà
prévu dans notre projet dans le
programme initial de premier tour donc
il est évidemment toujours d'actualité
je pense au développement des circuits
courts je pense à une alimentation
durable
je pense également au télétravail on
avait prévu dans ce projet de créer un
espace de coworking de télétravail c'est
évidemment toujours d'actualité ou aussi
une maison de service public qui servira
aussi maintenant dans l'après crise à
accompagner les demandeurs d'emploi et
aussi tous les acteurs économiques qui
ont besoin de d'accomplir des démarches
administratives pour leur relance et la
reprise d'activité
[Applaudissements]
alors la première décision ce sera de
faire face à la crise et ce sera de
répondre à la fois aux préoccupations du
quotidien des meusiens mais aussi de se
projeter sur l'avenir très proche
à commencer par la rentrée scolaire de
septembre qui sera un défi et un enjeu
aussi pour nous au niveau local avec le
retard de l'école dé ou dumoulin qui va
falloir s'adapter à cette question là on
va lancer aussi une conférence locale
des solidarités pour inventer de
nouvelles solidarités pérenniser dé
solidarité qu'on a pu voir immergé
pendant le confinement et qui convient
aujourd'hui de pérenniser notamment la
destination des personnes fragiles et
isolées
et puis évidemment on apportera tout
notre soutien aux acteurs économiques et
associatifs dans leur reprise d'activité
[Applaudissements]
et ne manquez pas un nouveau numéro de
nos débats en vue de ce scrutin des
municipales ce mercredi soir c'est avec
les candidats pour la ville de
guyancourt débat à avoir sur tv 78
écouter aussi sur radio sensations
yvelines fréquence 98 points 4
[Musique]
le point à présent sur l'épidémie de
coronavirus qui a fait dans le
département 516 victime soit 2
supplémentaires en 24 heures les
derniers chiffres communiqués hier par
santé publique francs sont encore sur
une pente descendante 408 patients
étaient hospitalisés hier sur le
territoire à 23 ans - entre lundi et
mardi 23 c'est aussi le nombre de
patients toujours en réanimation une
statistique est stable est depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire 2000 108
personnes ont été guéries de lakovic 19
après un passage à l'hôpital sur le
territoire et bien que l'épidémie soit
en recul le respect des gestes barrières
reste la meilleure solution pour contrer
ce virus notamment porter un masque et
qui est encore vivement recommandée dans
l'espace public à saint cyr l'école la
municipalité a mis en place la mascc
mobile une camionnette sillonnent les
quartiers de la ville pour mettre des
masques aux habitants hier mardi la
distribution se dérouler rue gérard
philipe lucien sampaix pierre courtade
environ 100 masques sont remis à chaque
tournée pour un total de 3000 protection
distribués pour cette opération les
propos recueillis par mathilde et demi
en charge des masques dont on tourne une
demi heure dans le quartier ensuite on
se pose à un point
les gens viennent donc soit ils sont
déjà inscrits sur l'application soit une
ne sont pas et on le fait directement il
faut venir avec des documents et on leur
donne leur masque pas pour chercher des
masques pour se protéger et protéger les
autres
on est trois grandes personnes plus de
deux ans à la maison les utilisent pour
le transport quand on se retrouve tous
en magasin le front commun des douze
maires de saint quentin en yvelines le
10 juin dernier ils ont écrit un
courrier au ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner l'objet demandé de
renforcer l'arsenal juridique et
législatif contre les rodéos urbains est
les élus demandent également être reçues
sur le sujet afin de témoigner de leur
expérience de terrain avec le
confinement le phénomène se serait
amplifiée dans les villes mettant à mal
sécurité et tranquillité publique
fin mai christophe castaner avait
annoncé de son côté le lancement d'un
plan d'action pour lutter contre les
rodéos urbains le sport avec ce retour
pour les pistards de l'équipe de france
au vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines ils ont repris
l'entraînement la semaine dernière après
trois mois d'arrêt et pour permettre ces
retrouvailles
un protocole strict a été mise en place
les détails de michael et demi d'euros
l'équipe de france de retour au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
les pistards tricolore pas encore au
complet peuvent de nouveau s'entraîner
depuis ce jeudi 10 juin sur la piste
les premiers coups de pédales après
trois mois d'arrêt je suis super
contente franchement ça fait vraiment
plaisir de retrouver tout le groupe
les coéquipiers les coach le staff ça
fait vraiment du bien ça faisait bizarre
parce que ça faisait longtemps qu'on est
pas rouler sur la piste de rouler sur en
eau et en os avec l'inclinaison ça ça
fait un peu pas peur mais on appréhende
un peu la première fois même si ça se
passe toujours très bien
le premier virage ça fait un peu bizarre
mais au bout de l'effort
c'est comme si on n'était jamais parti
pour reprendre en toute sécurité un
protocole strict antico vite 19 a été
mise en place dans la structure
on a le port du masque bon là on l'a pas
parce qu'on est sur notre vélo mais les
entraîneurs ont
on les masques on quand on arrive quand
on entre dans le vélodrome c'est
désinfection des mains on a le port du
masque pour voyager entre les vestiaires
les salles de tout ça on a chacun notre
table chacun notre emplacement qu'on
change pas et voilà après on nettoie
chaque fois quand on arrive quand on
repart les pistards de l'équipe de
france attendent maintenant une
clarification sur le calendrier des
compétitions internationales
les sportifs pourrait ne pas courir
avant la mi octobre date des prochains
championnats d'europe sur piste qui
devrait être organisé en bulgarie une
autre reprise celle des salles de cinéma
autorisés à ouvrir depuis lundi dernier
l'occasion rêvée pour nous de vous
proposer à nouveau notre rubrique
hebdomadaire dans les salles pour cette
première poste confinement patrick
jacques de dixmude est allé à la
rencontre du grenier à sel attrape ou
les projections reprendront la semaine
prochaine bonjour à tous avaient tous
remarqué ça y est c'est la rouverture
des cinémas au grenier à sel nous avons
décidé de rouvrir le mardi 30 juin à
20h45
pour cela nous vous avons concocté un
petit programme spécial nous avons une
avant-première donc le 30 juin à 20h45
il s'agit du film voir le jour un film
de marion laine avec sandrine bonnaire
et aure atika c'est un film qui se passe
dans le milieu médical avec
une des infirmières
maternité et donc avec tous les sujets
qu'on a pu voir ces derniers temps ça
tombe à point nommé
ça va nous donner du grain à moudre pour
notre réflexion et c'est super donc ce
sera mardi 30 juin à 20h45
il a survécu mais obtint tu avais pas lu
son dossier par marie claude tu sais
comment c'est combien je sais c'est
celui qui te garde oui série oui il a
raison de porter plainte parce que y'en
a marre de ces conditions sans pour
l'instant c'est moi qui leur sert de
bouc émissaire alors quand ça va depuis
tant que tu travailles tu es l'habitude
non non je m'habitue pas en ce qui
concerne les conditions sanitaires
maintenant le port du masque est
obligatoire dans les halls et dans les
circulations espaces de circulation pour
aller aux toilettes pour vous déplacer
il faut un masque est obligatoire et
nous n'avons pas ne fournissons pas donc
pensé avoir le vôtre sinon vous ne
pourrez pas rentrer il faudra laisser un
fauteuil m autour de vous à droite et à
gauche
que vous soyez si vous êtes en famille
ce sera à gauche et à droite de votre
famille voilà donc nous vous donnons
rendez-vous mardi 30 juin pour le mot
grande réouverture de ces vins grenier à
sel
à bientôt
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité très belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]